hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from round
nine of the 2022
tata steel masters
on the white end magnus carlson
and he's paired against shakriar mahmud
yarov
opening wise
it's a catalan
often leading to rich play often
involving white
gambiting upon
that's the case in this game
a few takeaways for me from this one
are related to
the structure
and also
move order or
the timing of certain moves
if you're a teacher and you're looking
for some good material on those topics i
think this is a good game to dig deeper
into
i anticipate only scratching the surface
with some of the structures i share
and it's probably for intermediate
students maybe beyond
so this check on b4
uh how do we deal with it how do we
block it's with the bishop
white still has dreams of
developing the queen knight to its
favorite square
a5
black is welcome to white initiating the
exchange the rook would be freed
and black would care more more about
that rook activity than having doubled b
pawns
there's an additional point a secondary
reason behind a5 that will be revealed
soon enough
outside castle
and now in this movie e3 not the most
common
eighth move
this is a moment i'd like to draw some
attention to
more common than e3 is queen c2
and one of the top games you'll find
with queen c2 is from 2020
newpom nishi versus carlson
carlson's reply to queen c2
bishop captures bishop
now just moments ago i said the queen
knight has dreams of going to c3
well with the queen already developed
white continued to develop recapturing
with the queen knight in this case
now
in this game e3 was on board
first thing to note
d4 is now strengthened
and
black cannot should
not capture on d2 in this case it's
important not to treat e3 the same way
as queen c2
let's see why
bishop captures bishop in this case
would be bad for black because white has
a new way to recapture on d2
with
the already developed knight
after knight f takes d2 note what's
happening
bishop's eyes are opened up
c4 is hit
the b pawn is pinned which means there
is no b5
to defend the c4 pawn
and if there is no b5 to defend c4
there is no defending c4
white will soon win this pawn back and
be better in really every way
alright the short story here is don't
bite on d2
okay in the game it's rook a6
first thought you're off the diagonal
for me at least you're off the diagonal
another point is that the rook is now in
a defended square and that detail
matters that has an influence
that draws our attention to move order
here
in the game it's rook a6
and then next up b5
those two are not interchangeable
if black wants to maintain control over
c4
with a pawn
let's see why
if black begins with b5
this is how white can react
a4
let's go with c6
the structure gets broken down
we see a problem with having an
unprotected rook on a8 white has just
won a piece
take the bishop there goes your rook
if black tries to be clever at this
moment
inserting this capture and in betweener
hang on once more we get to see this
underdeveloping reply
under developing recapture
and now
the c6 pawn is
pinned move order matters
rook a6 first
queen c2 in the game
b5 a4 c6 black clings to the extra pawn
one of the questions i had for myself i
had
many questions for myself in preparing
for this
video so a lot too
a lot of different structures a lot of
different stuff packed into this one
game
one of the thoughts i had is can white
not consider one of those preemptive
moves on this move
uh move nine
uh why not start with a4 here
you know b why wait for b5
to play a4
if white plays a4 right now
it's
it's not as effective
why do i think this well it's because
it's not creating tension white is
not
in a position now to one day make a
capture and free the rook that's a nice
positive for white to have that's why
it's normally better to wait for the the
pawn to be on b5 before playing a4
white doesn't have that in this position
if you go with a form
how could black proceed if white
goes with a4 in this position i want to
play out some moves so you can get a
feel
this is primarily for
players who may be playing from the
black side here we can get an idea
as to how we can find some good squares
for our pieces this is as far as i want
to take it
in this final position white is the side
who's actually up a pawn but it will
soon be one back
e5 is now in there since white doesn't
have as much control over e5 anymore
black could get that in and we can
clearly see an open lane
for that bishop
it will find a productive role soon
enough
okay there is no a4 in this game instead
it is queen c2 we have the following
structure
on the black queen side
and some pressure now on b5
that is defended with rook b6
this is a
fairly brief game a 27 mover
uh move 12 by carlson
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find what white's
next play is
okay here we go
e4
white does have a central majority has
had a central majority ever since move
four
by black d takes c4 and now it is in
motion
maybe d5 or e5 nearby
from here bishop e7
this was carlson's first
think
he spent about 14 mil uh 14
minutes on his next move
and
this is where i spent a lot of time
myself in trying to
understand what carlson was what was
maybe running through his mind here what
other move he's spending so much time
here what was the other move he was
considering this isn't some
only move position so what were his
candidate moves is something that that
cross crossed my mind at this moment
so an important stage in the game for
sure
his decision
on move 13 is to play e5
uh a favorite move of alpha zero
this is uh when alpha zero hit the scene
we've seen this white pawn established
on e5 time and time again
alpha zero playing against you know
alpha zero as white playing against
you know stock fish
uh where stockfish was playing the
french defense or even a queen's indian
defense
e5 time and time again it's a it's a
strong
uh pawn to establish
it drives the king knight away from its
favorite square it's often a catalyst
for an attack against the black king
side
may one day pave the way for the queen
taking up a nice post on g4 now that the
knight is not there
so
an additional point is that it fixes
this pawn so there still remains a
question mark over black's light square
bishop where is that open diagonal for
the light square bishop
okay
one of the downsides with e5 you do give
up a very big square to the black pieces
namely
d5 the knight hops right in there in
this game
and only at this stage do we have white
now capture on b5 note the timing
of this move that was a possibility for
a few moves now a takes b5 y is maybe
now the time to go ahead and capture on
b5
there's a lot to unpack
in this one
these half moves there's a lot to
dig into
a couple things to note with this
capture it is not only white who is
helped when you go ahead and capture on
b5 it's true the rook is unleashed
but after this recapture this is how it
played out in the game c takes b
followed
you'll note that c6 is vacant
this knight
has a jump on c6 exerting pressure on
white's center
this bishop
just moments ago i said it maybe has a
question mark over its head maybe not so
much anymore
it goes to b7 and functions on this long
diagonal pretty well
there's a trade-off here
when white goes ahead and initiates the
exchange on v5 the rook is helped but so
too are black's queenside miners
so
this 14 minute think by carlson on move
13
what was he considering
e5 the move played in the game and
probably
this capture first
why is that why was he going maybe back
and forth between these two moves what's
the difference between the move order
here
let's have a look at it the move played
in the game e5
knight d5
and now a takes b5
at this stage here mahmud
had a think himself he spent about 15
minutes
black has an option
he doesn't have to go ahead and take on
b5
uh
this is how it played out in the game
chop on b5
the knights were exchanged and carlson
ended up landing a skewer he ended up
winning some material
black has another option at this point
he can duck the knight exchange if he
wants
he could go into b4 hit the queen
and only then recapture
maybe white takes on a5 straight away or
drifts over to this nice post on g4
opposite the king
maybe this is uh you know
mahmoud yarov was not welcome to
this quick transfer of the queen or
simply had a preference for
you know playing down the exchange
having a nice structure and some good uh
placement for the pieces
uh he assessed uh
you know the the structure in the game
is maybe uh you know he clearly
preferred the structure he got in the
game
now
here's a question i had for myself at
this moment right here this is the
moment carlson had his think
why did he start with e5
if you switch the move order if you
start with a takes b5
and only then
play e5
aren't you limiting black's replies is
something i thought to myself
right because after knight d5 here
white's on move
white can now take the knight
and then
land the skewer
why not go in that direction why not
start with a takes b
aren't you limiting black's options
if you go with this and then that
not quite
if you start with this move order a
takes b and then e5
black could take a detour he doesn't
have to go into d5 he could say
i'll go to e8
i'll find
an active role on c6
i'll have this open diagonal i'll jump
my knight into c6 there is a different
route
for the black knight if
white begins with a takes b
and then goes with e5 it could go back
to that e8 square
okay in this game e5
first
knight d5
and then we have a takes b5 another
point to note another structure that
could surface
is
well maybe instead of this capture why
doesn't carlson go ahead and take the
knight on d5
well
this structure
no black is able to take towards the
center
that's
nice to have in there it's true white
would be able to land a skewer
but check out this resulting structure
it's true white gets the exchange
also has a past pawn
but what's the way forward for
white the computer is still a fan of
this position for white
but
black has a pretty solid structure
and it has a two to one majority this
pawn is under control
it's already a a critical position for
white there's a key move for white to
play in this position if you don't play
it you might find yourself on your back
foot for the remainder of the game
we'll see what that is at a later stage
in the actual game
but this is another structure that's you
really have to spend some time to try
and assess
it's definitely
unbalanced
structurally minor uh structurally and
you know we have the exchange
um no black is down the exchange here
not a decision that carlson went for
at the end of the day
he captures on b5
c takes b
knight takes knight
pawn takes knight and the skewer is on
board
one other note here is if you go ahead
and try and
uh duck this skewer
capturing with the queen
there's a problem with that
the problem is knight g5
and that's gonna hurt which one do you
want
you want your queen or your king to fall
okay so
it's e takes d5
and bishop takes a5 this was not a
blunder you could see
i imagine many many viewers watching the
game live may have bought to uh thought
to the thought to themselves oh my media
have blundered
no he didn't this was uh this was no
accident this was an on purpose
he went in for this
exchange sacrifice
he is giving value to
what exactly
um
it's nice that this bishop has a nice
post finally
now that the there's this capture on d5
this is the big positive for black
this majority on the queen side and also
uh the pressure on d4
with this sequence
with white going in for this material
grab
black's
pieces are are getting developed they're
finding good posts queen on b6 knight on
c6 are
are very nice posts
so how did play follow from here we have
rook to a8
this pawn is
it seems like it's up for grabs but
you know not exactly if black goes ahead
and
meets this rook a8 move with the capture
on d4 white can take
it's nice that this bishop's eyes are
finally opened
and we have this rook d1 move white's
getting this pawn back soon enough and
should be the one benefiting with more
open files
yeah so not not a good idea to go ahead
and take on d4 here
in the game we have h6
um one of the
one of the better moves in this position
in the computer zides in the computer's
eyes instead of h6
is to immediately
uh carry on with b4
to to get going straight away with uh
this majority
um
the move played in the game is h6
the computer points out
that
white can look to give the exchange
right back and try to
break in on the light squares
however slight it is
you know h6 it does somewhat weaken g6
this is an interesting moment for white
this was worth considering capturing the
bishop
and then playing queen to f5
does hit the rook and it paves the way
for this e6 advance i'll play out some
moves here
these are considered some of the better
moves you can't even
go ahead and take this pawn there'd be a
problem
with the knight jumping into e5 so
black would have to play this one we
could see that the light squares white
is giving back the exchange but
the light squares are being broken down
with this sequence of moves
white being able to get in that e6 move
is super disruptive
to the light squares on black's king
side not something that black went or
excuse me white went for
instead he doubled rooks
and we have from here bishop to e6
once more if there's this capture we're
gonna have a similar story the rook
simply goes to d1 uh from a1 instead of
f1
so no capture on d4 here instead bishop
to e6
queen to d1
b4
and now we have a key moment in the game
uh i'll throw this one to you as a pop
quiz
uh white to move what would you play
here feel free to pause the video
okay critical moment in the game
the move played
b3
um it is
what's the first comment i can make
about b3
it's never too late to challenge a duo
we see this uh right out of the openings
in the game
you know whenever there's a duo it's
often challenged we are 20 moves into
this game it feels like
we're in an ending now
b3
is an important move here
let's see why
if white makes us a passing move let me
let me make a move that
maybe isn't 100 passing you you could
see maybe many players make a move like
h3
what might the reasoning be well i have
a new square for my king i'm stopping a
pin
okay
there's a problem with h3 though
what's the problem
black would be able to play
b3
note the value
of b3
what is it doing well it's a step closer
to
uh creating a past pawn
uh now in the game b3 c3 was on board
black gets a past pawn in this way the
big difference black gets a connected
pass pawn in the game
the big difference though if you were to
play h3 here if black gets in b3 himself
b4 opens up
to
not only the knight
but the bishop
why is this a big deal
let's see i'm going to make some moves
let's let me go with the rook exchange
right
what is what is what does white do here
as a follow-up
how do you move forward
let's i'm not sure how to even move
forward here for white let's make
another somewhat passing move
we could see this knight jump into b4
once more not quite sure how to improve
for white let's say let's say a pawn
move
look at the jumps by the knight c2 d3 i
even found a funny one
something that looks uh
something that's
optically
interesting
knight a4 knight to a2
anything stick out to you about this
position
check out this diagonal
that's pretty cool a conex7
this rook is cut off
and this bishop is ready to slip in here
and maybe nearby there can be a c3
advance
this isn't super far-fetched you could
see
many players go ahead and make a useful
looking move like
h3 and not appreciating how valuable it
is for black
to have b3 in and b4 vacant for
multiple pieces
that would be
an amazing piece a knight on b4
and it's not clear how white makes
progress this is a super solid
uh construction
so
important moment a moment carlson
weighed carefully
he spent about 12 minutes on this move
here
b3 on board
it has an influence on the duo
if white is able to capture
and black recaptures he'd have two
connected past pawns but then again this
guy is ready to maybe advance
so for example
in the game c3 was played
if black plays queen b5 we can have this
capture
and now there's even a move like knight
to h4 paving the way for
a d5 advance so yes these two are they
certainly are scary but this is hitting
pretty fast
white is winning from this position this
knight maybe even has an eye on jumping
into f5 if this bishop tries to blockade
okay it's a way forward
if that structure comes about in the
game
what do we have it is c3
what else can we have a look at if black
goes ahead and captures
how can black
how can white follow up
white can first kick the queen away from
this d4 point right if you immediately
recapture
black can now go ahead and win out on d4
so the idea here would be to meet
c takes b3 certainly
one of the continuations white had to
run the numbers on what am i doing if
black simply takes well
you kick the queen away from d4
and only then pick up the pawn
okay so in this game
c3 on board connected past pawn
from here we have rook a6
releasing some pressure on d4 so that
this guy can now maneuver
somewhere else where does he go
knight e1 a best move
looking forward to maybe c2
but more aggressively that c that c3
square is uh is one that comes to mind
you may even
look forward to uh the f4 square one day
so put some more pressure on d5 but we
have some action in the center now
with f6
knight d3 straight away
f takes e5 follows
knight takes e5
knight takes knight
rook takes bishop
and after c2 we have
one final move this game
queen to e1
and black resigns
this pawn is just a step away from
queening but
it's uh black is down material and is
gonna lose some more material soon
enough
one of these two are going to fall
d5 is going to fall
there really isn't a good solution here
one of the lines i had to look at is
knight to d3
but you could go ahead and take on d5
this is one of the fun variations to
have a look at i guess
if knight takes queen
right we get the queen back discovered
check
take the queen we're upper rook in this
position
ready to win the night win the pawn
that's not working anything else to have
a look at if knight c6
simply take on this square knight is hit
bishop's ready to fall
this is this pawn is not dangerous
enough
so white is completely winning at this
point queen to e1 final move of this
game a very interesting one
as mentioned a lot of different
structures to
try to wrap one's head around
excellent game a lot to learn from this
one
let's have a look at
a quick look at
the tail the tape on this one
there we go we can see
that this was a very high level game
at the end of the day carlson
had an average centipalm loss of 11 to
mamadyarov's
33.
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you